voilà donc je voulais vous remercier
enfin vous et toute la communauté des
cheaters pour le temps que vous donnez
sans être grassement payés si j'ai bien
compris dans cette affaire dans la
première partie de cet échange je vais
effectivement vous parler de quelque
chose qui est d'actualité qui est le
manifeste que le shift a commencé à
promouvoir un bas bruit pour le moment
mais qui devrait passer à plus au bruit
ici quelques semaines et il ya un an et
demi une discussion de bistrot a lieu
entre un homme s'appelle andré jean
guérin et moi et je lui dis tiens est-ce
que tu serais d'accord pour faire un
truc qui existerait au moment des
élections présidentielles qui serait en
fait une réédition du pacte écologique
donc elle j'ai trempé il ya maintenant
quelques années et qui serait un
ensemble de mesures on proposerait dans
le débat public à l'approbation des
candidats en disant pas si on veut être
sérieux sur la question voilà ce qu'on
devrait faire c'est comme ça qu'il est
manifeste dans lequel on a évidemment
recyclé toute une partie de trucs qu'on
avait déjà fait avant et on va boucher
quelques trous
par exemple on n'avait jamais travaillé
sur l'agriculture donc on a fait tout un
tas de savants calculs sur qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire sur l'agriculture
ceux là où on a hérité de l'expérience
pacte c'est qu'on a repris une des
règles on s'était fixé dans le pacte qui
ait pas plus de dix mesures on va
prendre dans les secteurs principaux la
première mesure qu'il faut faire c'est
qu'ils aient pas contournable parce que
cette façon si on fait pas celle là n'a
aucune chance d'arriver à une baisse
significative des émissions et donc
c'est comme ça qu'est née la philosophie
des neuf propositions sur lesquelles on
a travaillé
c'est à chaque fois on prend un secteur
on prend la mesure du premier en eau qui
est celle à laquelle on n'échappe pas si
on veut être sérieux sur la question
il faut absolument séparer le manifeste
et en faire une pétition de principe des
neuf proposition qui n'engage pas les
signataires donc en fait on va séparer
au bout du bout la production du chiffre
en deux morceaux un manifeste que
décemment une personne moralement
normalement constitué ne peut pas
refuser de signer ça dit en gros on
n'attend pas c'est à nous de nous y
coller et c'est un devoir moral et en
plus ça tombe bien c'est une opportunité
pour un pays où pourrait être plus
exactement pour
non l'europe qui a une culture
historique de la gestion de la
contrainte on va faire signer un certain
nombre de têtes couronnées en s'y
prenant à bas bruit et le jour où on
passe au grand public ont dit vous avez
vu le patron de vinci il a signé sa
patron de la sncf aussi le mec qui gère
votre épargne à le patron cnp assurances
a aussi signé patron ag2r acier etc
parce que vous voulez dire soutenir ce
truc et c'est exactement comme ça qu'on
est en train de s'y prendre c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on fait de l' approche
directe auprès d'un certain nombre de
têtes couronnées commence à avoir une
liste par complètement ridicule qu'il
faut encore muscler un mec est pas
complètement ridicule et on est allé
taper dans les gens qui sont dans votre
public habituel c'est-à-dire dans le
monde économique dans le monde
académique et dans le monde et aux
fonctionnaires que le manifeste a été
construit autour de propositions
d'actions sectorielles on va s'occuper
de faire des bâtiments comme ceux ci
comme cela voilà ça c'est sectorielle sa
noble et gagnant ça donne aussi des
perdants dans sa tombe les gagnants on
va s'occuper de faire des voitures qui
correspondent à telle ou telle
caractéristique
voilà ça ça vous dit ben voilà il y aura
du boulot pour les mecs de psa à sochaux
s'ils veulent bien faire des babioles
comme ceux ci et comme cela on va
s'occuper de remettre un peu d'argent
dans le réseau ferré et en particulier
celui qui permet d'assurer les échanges
internationaux mais ça c'est pareil
comprennent quels sont les métiers
associés à ça la différence avec le
pacte elle est dans l'adn du shift alors
je dis pas que ça va marcher alors que
je vais pas vous faire le coup de
maquereaux - mais la différence avec le
pacte elle est dans l'adn du shift et
les gens qu'on va chercher en ce moment
quand nicolas hulot est allé chercher
ses soutiens et s'est adressé par ce que
il était très populaire très connu du
grand public directement au grand public
donc il a pu arriver au près et par
ailleurs les mesures qu'on proposait
étaient des mesures qui étaient
qualitative après les propositions qui
ont été amenés dans le débat n'était pas
directement taillé pour le monde
économique parce qu'elle n'était pas
quantifié sur le plan économique
donc c'était très facile de les
repousser en disant ça coûte trop cher
c'est machin c'est ceci c'est cela là on
a pris les devants on a quantifié toutes
les mesures donc on a dit voilà si on
veut se débarrasser du charbon en europe
et bien si vous mettez que des réacteurs
nucléaires partout ces temps si vous
m'aidez que des éoliennes partout c'est
un pareil pour l'isolation des bâtiments
pareils pour les véhicules à dos les
être pareil pour le train et c'est à
chaque fois
qu'est-ce qu'on va demander aux
politiques c'était à la dernière
question on va leur demander une fois
que le manifeste est lancé dans grand
public de prendre un engagement et un
seul c'est sylvain de forges là qu'a eu
cette idée si je suis élu président je
m'engage à demander au conseil européen
de demander à la commission de produits
sous un an une stratégie cohérente pour
décarbonés l'europe au meilleur coût
économique points donc ça dit en gros
parce que une fois que vous avez donné
mandat à la commission de produire un
livre blanc l'histoire montre que le
livre blanc devient un livre vert puis
un projet de directive puis et c est en
fait nos débuts de l'histoire
on va essayer de le prendre alors on
s'est bien gardée dans la partie
électricité de dire il faut en faire ou
il faut pas en faire on a nommé l'ennemi
est derrière le discours qu'on a
l'intention de tenir ces si vous êtes
intimement persuadé que vous allez vous
en débarrasser avec juste des nouvelles
zr pour pas beaucoup plus cher que s'est
pas faite le donc on a essayé de trouver
une manière de ne pas mettre ça au
centre du débat
donc nous on n'en parle pas bon et je le
redis les gens qui sont convaincus que
ils disent que maintenant qu'ils à la
parité machin chouette etc on peut faire
un visionnaire le problème est donc si
on déplace sur le terrain de ce qu'on a
envie de faire ce que j'espère c'est que
en gros la cristallisation sur le
nucléaire se dissoudra dans un truc qui
tissent qui sera un projet de société
plus large laissé à part car on est un
peu aidé quand même
dans cette croisade par le fait que de
plus en plus de gens voient l'expérience
allemande qu'elle est en cours de route
alors que je rappelle qu'ils ont quand
même 250 milliards d'euros d'excédent
commercial par an donc du pognon à
présent 1
c'est pas notre cas pourtant c'est déjà
en train de caler en cours de route
un truc qui perturbe maintenant les gens
c'est de se dire d'abord écart en cours
de route puis tiens c'est marrant
maintenant les anticyclones les
particules fines sont sur le nord
bon ça commence à venir selon on voit ça
dans des bulletins météo maintenant
bulletin météo de bfr et main qui a fait
par une copine
il projette ce n'est pas pour rien les
projets des cartes avec la commission
particules fines je pense que la majeure
partie des gens qui vont acheter ce
qu'on essaye de leur enfant achète une
ambitions mégalomaniaques de
reconstruction de l'europe autour
d'autres choses qu'un marché unique
achète une ambitions mégalomaniaques de
préserver la paix achète une ambitions
mégalomaniaques de se donner des défis
qui nous font un peu rêver même si ça
nous fait un peu transpirer donc je le
redis le manifeste ne sera utile visible
appropriée par ces gens là que si ça
leur amène un bénéfice politique et un
bénéfice politique c'est je capture des
électeurs où je me fais pas le voir des
biens si je ne signe pas alors parce
qu'une bonne partie des mesures qu'on
propose ou un ancrage européen
aujourd'hui si vous voulez supprimer de
charbon de la production électrique
aucun pays en restant dans le cadre
actuel des institutions européennes ne
peut le faire sans que l'europe s'en
mêle c'est comme ça si vous voulez
diminuer la consommation des véhicules
qu'on vend en europe
aujourd'hui ça passe par la commission
qui réglemente les émissions donc la
consommation des véhicules neufs ont en
europe
si vous voulez réglementé l'efficacité
énergétique des bâtiments il ya déjà des
directives européennes en ce sens alors
ça veut pas dire vous puissiez rien
faire au niveau national et par ailleurs
comme je crois que le projet européen
était un beau projet c'est à dire
va faire des trucs ensemble pour éviter
de se taper dessus qui est
raisonnablement bien marché pendant 70
ans eh bien on pense qu'on peut très
bien avoir d'entrée de jeu un projet
européen se déclinant au niveau de la
france
mais après il va pas dès qu'ils aient la
même manière on va faire une déclinaison
des investissements nécessaires et les
efforts nécessaires au niveau français
c'est bien dans ce sens là que l'on va
ça ne sera un projet européen pour finir
là-dessus que si un projet politique à
un pays politiquement majeur dit je
souhaite que ce soit le cas c'est comme
ça que l'europe s'est faite de manière
bottom up avec des poids lourds
politiques qui ont dit on va faire des
trucs ensemble est alors aujourd'hui si
vous procéder par élimination il y en a
qu'un qui puisse s'emparer de ce projet
elle a pas deux il y en a qu'un
parce que si on arrive à trouver
quelqu'un qui se dit qu'il peut essayer
de laisser son nom dans l'histoire en
reconstruisant l'europe comme elle a été
construite à ses débuts autour d'accords
sur l'énergie rappelle que ce qui a
fondé l'europe c'est la communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier
puis derrière auratum donc d'autres
étaient donc on dit très bien on revient
aux sources
on veut la paix on part de l'énergie ça
vous donne quoi la décarbonation
l'économie donc vous avez un projet qui
peut permettre d'arriver en tapant du
poing sur la table
par la voix de marine le pen en disant
je vais tout casser mais dans un monde
totalement différent qui ajoute on
construire
oui